bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got hani
here with me thank you so much for doing
this
thanks for having me all right uh what
is going on
in the world of institutional adoption
of crypto
in public markets i feel like you are
the maybe the world's expert
on all of this what's happening
yeah so um we're based in europe so i
can talk a lot about uh institutional
adoption there
that's where our products are um
registered listed that's where they get
sold
um we have seen a lot of demand
primarily from fund managers independent
asset
managers family offices private banks
uh it's no longer just dipping their
toes in
we see people talking about allocating
10 20 30 million dollars across
a number of different strategies um
bitcoin is
sometimes the gateway into all of this
sometimes it's not and so we've had
uh people come in on uh smart contracts
we've had some people come in
more recently with the coinbase news on
binance
and starting to see well the exchanges
are actually printing cash they're
making real revenues you can
look at them as uh defensible businesses
with moats and all that
and a bunch of people have come in and
wanted to invest
in those kinds of things and so i think
in terms of
um pension funds insurance companies
like
really big institutional guys they're
not in yet
uh and and it will be a while uh
we've had some conversations they're
they're interested but they're very
slow-moving and it's it's going to be i
think
a long time before they're really in but
yeah
um asset managers private banks family
offices high net worth
are all more than dipping their toes in
so let's talk about the business that
you have because you basically have kind
of two sides of the business
yeah and i should stay up front i'm an
investor so i'm a big fan and obviously
very long
uh one is a moon and the other is 21
shares
what is the difference between those two
it's very simple so we do etps etfs
under 21 shares
and we do tokens under a moon okay and
when
uh you say etps ets i think most people
know what an etf is what is an etp
and etp is basically what the swiss call
an exchange traded commodity and it is
it is
what the swiss specifically call it uh
sometimes you go
across the border in germany and
suddenly they want to call it an etn or
sometimes you go elsewhere and they want
to call it an etc
in europe as opposed to the united
states you cannot do
an etf on a single asset etfs have to in
order for them to be what's called
u-sits
compliant they have to have a diversity
requirement and you have to have a
number of elements in there so you could
do an index
as an etf but you can do a single asset
and so in europe not even
any of the commodities silver gold etc
are done as etfs so it's impossible to
do one there on the 21 share side talk
through like just some of the products
right so you have a bitcoin etp yeah
you have a eth etp yeah yeah what are
some of the other assets
so we have 14 total products um listed
on
the swiss german and austrian stock
exchanges
you can buy them using dollars francs
pounds or euros
bitcoin and ethereum are two very
obviously popular products
the other 12 products include a bunch of
single assets
some of which you can only purchase
through our company like polka dot
which isn't available on a lot of
exchanges um including coinbase in
europe
or coinbase globally actually uh so we
have a polka dot etp we have a binance
atp
we have a tezos income generating
staking etp
stakes on your behalf returns to the
dividends uh and
in addition to that i think we have
ripple bitcoin cash we just released
stellar and cardano last week
we also have the world's only indexes so
we have
four indexes uh one made by us three
made by independent third parties
including
the american company bitwise signum and
bitcoin swiss
and we also have the world's only listed
bitcoin
short so you can buy a product to hedge
or make a bet on uh the negative price
action of bitcoin
just as easily as buying a share so the
21 share side of the business like how
big is that from like an aum standpoint
uh yeah so things have escalated i think
since we last
chatted we were doing i i would say
probably 20 million when we last chatted
we were 27 million about a year ago uh
we're now at 2 billion
dollars in total aum uh and
if you look at the price movement in the
last year a lot of that isn't just the
price increasing
a lot of that is bigger checks from
family offices
private banks and a lot of retail
interest in europe as well
so two billion dollars in assets across
those 14 products
in the last 12 months yeah okay now when
you go and you look at the
immune side you said that you do tokens
explain the difference between the
tokens and the uh etps or etfs
sure so um etps etfs are
very regulated financial products um
they're structured as securities so in
many ways we take crypto and we
securitize it
in order for institutional um and
non-technical users to feel
comfortable making about on the asset
class tokens are on the exact opposite
end of that they're not securities
and they're listed in predominantly
today erc20 format
but we will soon list them in other
formats as well so you can imagine
a binance smart chain token for example
or something built on
uh another platform for us we just want
to
provide products to access the crypto
ecosystem
to users and what we found is
sometimes it's significantly easier for
certain populations to buy tokens
uh and for certain strategies as well
sometimes they're better in token form
and so whatever it is we can do on the
token side we'll we'll issue it there
whatever it is we can do on the etp side
we'll do that and
there are sometimes overlap so we have
both a
btc short token as well as a bitcoin
short atp
and that's fine how big is the immune
side
like and what is the interest you're
seeing there so the immune side
is unreleased so we're about to launch
the first four tokens
in uh about a month time
so we're launching with with a pretty
cool partner um haven't announced that
yet publicly but but you'll see it and
it'll be cool
um and we're launching we're going to
have a plan of launching both
um uh what are what we're calling
autopilot
tokens so they will go you buy a single
erc20 token and then it on your behalf
goes and
generates yield optimizing
rewards in some theme so we're going to
do that with liquidity
mining and we're going to do that with
lending so if you want to optimize all
the define lending protocols just buy
this token
and it will optimize that
programmatically airdrop you the
rewards uh on a on a daily basis on a
regular basis
we're also going to launch a number of
indexes so if you would like to bet
on the entire d5 ecosystem that's going
to be the first product
we're also going to launch a few more uh
interesting strategies there
so take like a defy index token how do
you determine
what goes in what doesn't go in is it
rebalancing like
just walk through that kind of
mechanisms of how one of these tokens
would work where you're
essentially buying like an index
exposure we're doing it in token form
yeah so um we take a look at a lot of
things in d5 we take a look at market
cap
and total value locked uh we have
certain
um tokens that we allow in so we have
the
you know a committee that takes a look
at this makes sure that we respect the
teams we know the teams we know who's
behind them
we like the vision we think this is um
worthy of
inclusion uh and that benefit is a
little bit subjective just whether or
not it is
eligible to even be considered but then
after that we we take
we take a hard look quantitatively at
what the ecosystem looks like
um how it how it functions how it's
growing and then we will do the weights
there uh rebalances regularly i think
the entire point is
that a lot of people believe in d5 as a
concept they think it's going places
that they think it's really
um quite innovative and interesting and
they would like to invest in it but
maybe not necessarily have the time to
dive into the specifics
um it's sort of like betting on i know
the brazilian economy by buying a
brazilian
index fund um and
what we want to do is we want to do that
on
um these themes so d5 being the first
one
but we'll also start thinking more about
other themes
as well as uh more momentum driven
things so
it's sometimes really really difficult
to see what is up and coming
we can programmatically do that which
should theoretically have
give you easier access to uh the new
things that people don't necessarily
know will be big yet
um and that that will be another way of
again buying a single token
leaving it setting it and forgetting it
and then it just does work on your
behalf programmatically
what do i actively manage tokens right
so what i mean by that
is obviously we've seen uh people in the
traditional world have a lot of success
by
uh raising uh etf that's actively
managed
can you do that in the kind of crypto
token world or is that not yet possible
i mean you can you can do whatever you
want i think depending on the
jurisdiction um
sometimes there are regulatory issues
with active management
um as a firm we we sort of decided very
very early on that we're not really
interested in active management we're
not interested in
endorsing any specific product
on the etp side all we look for is
whether it's investable or not
nothing more it's not an endorsement and
on on the token side are our committees
they are going to do something
similar where again we're going to try
and verify that these aren't scams but
beyond that it's not an endorsement
what we believe our company should be
doing is being a very neutral
um picks and shovels business right
we want to give you the building blocks
the tools
from which you can then go and using
your ideas your thoughts
uh go about and you know invest or
build out your strategy in some way that
is professional institutional grade
has the safeties you're not going to get
robbed the fees are low et cetera et
cetera
but we're not going to jump in it and
say we're going to you know
pick the winners or endorse this or
endorse that
when you think about in the etf etp side
right on the 21 shares
is the same thing true there as well in
terms of active management and just
saying hey whether it's a token or an
actual fund
uh we're not going to have the active
manager ourselves and we're also not
going to endorse anyone
so 100 um
there are ways of doing active
management
etfs and atps obviously there are a
couple of popular ones this year
um that have you know uh come out and
everyone is talking to them
i think it's important to realize that
active management is really really hard
it's sort of like venture capital we
know the top winners
and they do well but the industry
overall is
oftentimes not having great returns
active management's really really
difficult
and i would say that philosophically as
a company again we're not really
interested in active management we're
not interested in
picking stocks or we don't think we are
smart enough to do that we just want to
build the tools from which others can
then
use that and so in the same way we don't
endorse any specific product we believe
that's investable we don't think it's a
scam we believe the teams behind
the products that we are launching
believe in a vision believe in a mission
are working towards it in a professional
way
and beyond that we don't do much else we
don't do small cap stuff
on the etp side um and so it has to be
above a certain threshold that moves
constantly but guarantees as well that
especially on the etp side you're not
investing in like brand new
things they've they've matured a little
bit they've they've shown
some staying power um and then we give
you easier access to them
one of the people who appears to be
smart enough to do active management is
kathy
wood uh i know that you've done a bunch
of stuff with her
uh including she's now personally
invested in the business uh she's
joined the board of directors maybe talk
a little bit just about
her her involvement in the business and
kind of how this all came together sure
so um we we've always been huge fans of
kathy
um i mean if you think about the the
business and 21 shares being the first
thing we did
it's an etf issuer on the 21 shares side
and um kathy's pretty big on
in the etf world like before she hit the
mainstream and
was this huge figure that everyone knows
now um she was still
very very very um much a big deal within
the etf world so
my co-founder ran into her at one of
these um
exclusive etf uh product structurist
uh conference they hit it off we
developed a relationship chatted for
a year or so and then uh there came a
point where we
wanted to have an independent director
on our board um
and so kathy ended up doing that
in joining the board as well as um more
recently
she also became an investor in the
company and so
super super excited about that um
besides all of the things that we
hear about um on on the bitcoin and
crypto side
like she started investing in bitcoin in
2015 when it was 250
right i think people really under um
value how big of
a deal that is and how difficult it was
to do that at the time
especially for an institutional um fund
manager on wall street
but besides that what she's doing on
genomics
what um what she's doing with tesla what
she's doing with all of the other
product is
space exploration um etf that she just
came out with
it's really really innovative and we're
huge huge fans of the shop and we wanted
to
you know gather some knowledge um on
that one of the things that is really
um important and um
near and dear to our hearts is research
um and so
we believe really strongly that uh we
should build a brand that is trusted and
we should educate everybody
um if you think about the internet was
created in 1983
uh it took a while for people to fully
understand
maybe a decade later then the boom and
bust then web 2.0
then now we're starting to see the
rewards this is a generational thing and
and it
it's um as john oliver uh once said
crypto's everything you uh cryptos
everything people don't know about
finance and economics combined with
everything they don't know about
computer science and cryptography
and that venn diagram is tough and so we
seek to elucidate all of that
and we seek to publish
very deep research um as well as very
casual research we do it in five
languages now we do it in arabic
english french german and italian and in
addition to that we do
podcasts uh we print a quarterly
magazine
uh for institutional investors it's
awesome it looks great
um we should probably charge for it but
we give it away for free now
and for that kind of philosophy to then
um run into kathy where arc is an
acronym i think it stands for active
research knowledge
um most people don't realize that but
but arc is
all about research driving these
decisions and kathy's background as an
equity
research um as an equity research
analyst
um had a lot to do with honestly her big
bets and her vision
and how she's built the firm so we also
really overlapped there
and over the years we've stolen a lot of
how she's done research and and
that kind of thing and so it was very
nice to start working together
what do you think makes her so great is
it the research and just the constant
like
wanting to learn yeah i think i think
it's
the
when you when you do research it's it's
scientific it's not personal it's not
biased there's not a
huge you know selfish personality behind
it it's not egotistical
um it's very fair logical
scientific and as a result when you make
big bets
in that direction then it's not personal
and and you reap the rewards and i think
a lot of people appreciate that
wall street is full of um personalities
that you know will come on tv and scream
or have a certain
or scream on twitter or you know have a
certain sort of
reputation where that sometimes is
removed from
how their firms are doing or what their
investment strategies are
etc and on her the first thing she did
was
uh say that research should be open all
of these investment banks
are super closed they're super private
um they're charging so much for
this we shouldn't do that we should have
very strong
thesis that we really uh fundamentally
believe in and then we should share them
with the world
and so you can go and see you know an
excel spreadsheet of how they value
tesla
and all of that broken down and i think
people really really appreciate that
and then when you're right once they
appreciate it more and then when you're
right 17 times
then maybe you're on to something yeah
when you think about uh
the operation that you have going in
europe uh a lot of the stuff that you
have is not available in the united
states today that may change in the
future
uh talk a little bit just about the
difference that you see in the
institutional investors and the family
offices between europe and the u.s are
there
material differences that you can
identify or do you feel like
an institutional investor is an
institutional investor and so that
there's really not that much to kind of
call out there
uh yeah they have the same
no they have the same characteristics uh
oftentimes the
family office staff um is recruited from
from the same uh i guess cut from the
same cloth
wherever you go the interesting thing
about europe actually versus the united
states and family offices if i recall
correctly
the average family office in the u.s is
much smaller
like i think in america people will set
up family offices with 100
or 200 million of uh liquid assets
whereas in europe
the average to start is more like 500
million and so you get
sometimes the average the median that
you're speaking to is a larger
organization
got it and do you think that that's like
a cultural thing
is that a egotistical thing in the
united states of like people want to say
they have a family office like
what drives that i mean as
as an american i feel like it's it's a
good spirit of
um i'm ready i got this i'll grow
i feel confident about this uh who says
that the limit for me to
have this is 500 i think it's 100 i can
do it and i think there's a good
spirit of americanism actually in that i
appreciate it
yeah i mean it's just interesting that
that's something that you notice right
is the size of the family offices are
very different on the two different
geographies well it's sort of like
startups right uh one way of looking at
it and a lot of people
i think make this mistake and do it is
like i'm not ready yet to do a startup i
still need to
go and have 10 years of work experience
and i need to also maybe get some
experience on the investment side and
then
you know you only want to start a
startup when you're super
well qualified to do one and i think
i would argue as a person that did his
first company when he's 19 very rightly
so
america will reward people that go out
and try
um and you can try and fail and failure
is much more accepted in america than it
is in europe
um and as a result i think people take
bigger bets
which is why again it's the median like
the the minimum
is different in europe but obviously the
wealth is much much much much greater in
in the us yeah when you talk to
regulators uh kind of on different
geographies
is there a change in tone or
interest uh or kind of receptiveness to
this stuff
as we've seen one prices go up yeah but
also
two various institutions kind of over
the last six to eight months nine months
kind of come into the market and not
only come into the market but actually
be public about their participation
yeah so talking about regulators is a is
a tricky subject um and i can't talk
about any specific ones um
and you know before i share some
thoughts
you should know that we are speaking as
of today with
i want to say 16 different regulators so
this does not apply
to any any specific one of them um
in my experience um
the response can be varied but at the
end of the day
i haven't yet met a regulator that
was personally motivated to bring
something
down or to champion something like i
don't think it's a crusade
on on any part they're in my
humble experience very technocratic
folks whose sole
mandate or sometimes their biggest
mandate and their biggest concern
is protecting end investors that's
really it
um all of that other stuff is a
distraction
like price action bitcoin increasing in
price
i don't know that that really impacts
anything be beyond
well maybe the market is more uh
streamlined now
such that the average retail investor
won't
lose everything in a scam by wales
because the price action moved
you know so hard uh in one way or
another so i don't
i i don't think regulators are motivated
by the same things that
certainly investors or entrepreneurs are
and it's actually my my my personal
opinion on this is that
um they tend to do a great job most of
the time
we want to we want them to move faster
but of course we do because we
we move at a ridiculous speed as startup
founders
but at the end of the day they're very
well versed in this
um sometimes more than certain people in
the industry
and they're they're again they're just
trying to do
their mandate of protecting the end
investor and
if anything regulation has gone um
pretty well like there is a good trend
going
in most of the countries that we've
interacted with
certainly europe is is far ahead of of
the competition
but there are certain regulators that
are moving in asia we're going to
announce in the next quarter or so um
a bitcoin etf in in asia in apac we're
going to do one in the middle east
and we're going to continue doubling
down on europe and other territories and
again
regulators are smart receptive um
and aren't being personally motivated in
sometimes you see some weird comments on
there it has nothing to do with their
personal beliefs
uh they're very technocratic folks yeah
oh it's gr it's good to hear that right
it's a
positive for uh for the industry and
frankly a bullish tailwind
um when you think about recruiting how
has that changed is it now that
everybody that works on wall street uh
or institutional investors like hey i
got to quit my job and i want to go and
and work in this new industry
yeah is there still some lack of
receptivity in terms of uh folks just
like what's changed there over the last
maybe a year or so yeah so there's a lot
of
impact there from the price action um
are you mad that everyone's getting rich
and they're not i mean
i think a lot of people um in the
finance industry
can speak very directly about how broken
the finance industry is
and so a lot of the solutions
a lot of the problems that blockchain
bitcoin smart contracts
defies want to solve seek to solve um
they're very intimately aware
of those and so that's that's pretty
easy however
from a job security standpoint up until
recently it was a
higher hurdle but i would say at this
point
we have never had an easier time
recruiting from the traditional industry
a lot of it is inbound in a way that is
um
you know for someone that's been in
crypto for a long time is really
validating
you know we uh and how talented are the
people are they are these people that
are coming in that are you're like wow
this is incredible talent
or are these people who are like you
know uh lower
percentile performers in those other
organizations and they want to come into
crypto no no the heads of departments
the heads of departments um we we
recently made an offer to
uh and she's accepted and she'll become
um
our new head of sales to the head of the
departmented euronext which is a major
stock exchange
right um was was leading a number of
initiatives there
um we've um we've been able to
snag from traditional asset managers
traditional financial companies
country heads like the person that was
responsible for all of southern europe
the person that was responsible for all
of
switzerland all of germany um and again
a lot of this is inbound
a lot of this is inbound we we have
recruiters and obviously we try and seek
other people but
what is surprising to me is how many
people are just
interested in in this how many people
realize that the banking and financial
system
is broken there is something wrong and
maybe we're on to something
and they want to be a part of it yeah
what's so fascinating to me is not only
are you getting an increase in total
talent right coming inbound
but also the quality of talent is still
very high and what i wonder is how many
how much of this kind of talent leakage
right or brain drain from the wall
street firms
becomes a threat and also they realize
hey we're gonna lose a ton of people if
we don't start actually doing this as
well
so there's kind of like an economic
return uh that is a
incentive to get into it but also
there's this element of like literally
if these people can't work on this stuff
they're going to leave and therefore we
have to get into that business simply to
retain our best talent
yeah i i would argue that it's a part of
a longer
um tech impact on finance in general
like before there was crypto people were
leaving for silicon valley to do other
things
and so i think the financial industry
has had an issue retaining
top talent for for quite some time um
the top people in america at least
um go to silicon valley in my experience
a lot of people um then a lot of people
in finance will then switch to silicon
valley later
um and so i think that's i think that's
typically how
um how it's going i'm not sure that
i'm not sure that there's um
another strategy that the banks can have
besides embracing this and to their
credit
and not every bank there's some there's
some very bad um
[Music]
there's some very bad people that should
understand innovation more in the
financial world but to their credit
there are several top institutions who
have been
um quite early mavericks
and i think it will lead to very good
things for them
right um a lot of the recent news coming
out of uh i don't know goldman sachs
um i think jp morgan is doing some
really interesting things
um some of the early market makers like
the the traditional guys susquehanna and
jane street and flow traders
um the fact that they were in crypto
super super
early like drw owns cumberland that says
a lot of great things about both of them
yeah and so i think um the early
adopters and the people that made big
moves are going to be rewarded
really handsomely and the one last thing
i would say on this
and it's something that we in the
industry should really embrace it's
completely fine
to have skeptics that switch this
happened with jp morgan and jamie dimon
right and a lot of people will
attack jp morgan say you know you've
been against it for so long you're
acting hypocritical
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with admitting you're
wrong and they should be fully embraced
i would love
for we're obsessed with warren buffett
and monger and what they think i would
love for them to switch their mind and
i'll
i'll
i will hug them with open arms and
welcome them to the tribe you know
changing your mind is a sign of
intelligence right exactly that's fine
um one of the things i'm really
interested in i feel like it's like
literally like a trillion dollar
question in the industry right now is
all these institutions that are coming
in
how much do they resemble the retail
investors that came before them versus
their new breed of investment what i
mean by that is
um you know do they really have strong
hands
or not so one of the things is look at
bitcoin as a market structure
right we know that 60 of bitcoin or so
hasn't moved in the last 12 months
we know that more and more uh bitcoin is
coming off of exchanges on a daily basis
right and so you basically have this uh
majority
of bitcoin that is held by quote-unquote
strong hands people who they're not
trading they're not looking
to sell regardless of price volatility
up or down
like they just they hold for a long
period of time institutions come in and
frankly there's like two different
arguments right there's one argument
that says oh they're big institutions
they don't care about the volatility
they're going to hold very strong uh
whether the price goes up or down
they're not going to go and just dump
all the
um you know bitcoin they're doing this
because they're in the industry right
like they
had to go through a lot of pain and
probably internal hurdles and
bureaucracy to do it
so they're in the other argument is
bitcoin drops 50
and the first people run into the door
is tesla and jp morgan and you know
goldman and whoever and they're just
getting this thing off their balance
sheet and like
they actually are going to be the
weakest hands in the room
maybe the truth somewhere in between
there but just how do you think about
like
institutions compared to uh what to some
degree is almost like a non-economic
actor
that has been the retail investors that
have you know really kind of built this
industry over the last uh decade or so
yeah so i think we should um
specify a little bit the umbrella term
of institutional investors is too broad
if we compare family offices and ultra
high net worth
individuals who are i would argue the
driving
force of quote-unquote institutional
adoption in crypto today
they resemble a lot of retail in many
ways
it's a much larger check but it's
sometimes driven by the same
considerations we're still not doing
heavy investment committee meetings and
the bureaucracy that's associated with
it sometimes it can be driven by a
single or a group
um a single individual or a group
and largely the reasons that
have attracted retail and by the way the
reasons they've attracted early adopters
like us because i would argue where
we're not quite retail or institutional
are the same um a lot of people are
concerned with the amount of money
printing going on
a lot of people are concerned with the
inflation or lack thereof
a lot of people are concerned about
geopolitical risk
and family offices are
usually based on an individual or a
family and they're
equally concerned about the same things
and so i wouldn't worry too much about
hands um when it comes to ultra high net
worth and family offices and in our
experience
they're pretty pretty damn strong hands
um the price
sometimes guide rates in in a wild and
crazy
fashion and they don't move oftentimes
they buy more
and um you know our first product was
called
hodl for a reason and i i think that
that really translates one-to-one for
them
on the trading side we started seeing
um some trading firms go in
um and they're very different they're
just a different breed they're looking
to make short-term profits and they're
and they're advertising it um right
they're not shy about it
that is what they do uh but i would say
that anyone who makes an investment in
crypto
a meaningful one in my experience at
least talking to european family offices
they're planning on on holding it in a
similar
uh on a similar time horizon as a vc
fund as being an lp and a vc fund which
you know
seven to ten years minimum that kind of
thing outside of what i'll call
institutional
uh we also have retail institutional
corporates
and countries i feel like the other two
big thing
that you know has happened i say that
like
over the last like two three years
everyone's so focused on the
institutional investors
we almost forgot about corporations
right like there wasn't a lot of talk
over the last two three years about the
corporations and sure there are some
people who
had very great foresight and they wrote
about it you know years ago or something
but that was not a mainstream narrative
yeah michael saylor
elon musk jack dorsey a few others
mavericks
have completely changed that narrative
and now it's like every day
uh i was at mercado libre in latin
america largest publicly traded company
in in that uh region
uh they've now bought bitcoin uh you saw
metro mile
which is a kind of insurance tech
company recently came out and said not
only did they buy bitcoin for the
balance sheet
they're not going to accept bitcoin for
premium payments they're also going to
do
claim payouts in bitcoin if you want
that and so you can just start to see
okay here come the corporations
yeah and then obviously we have
countries the nefarious or kind of
malicious actors
from a u.s western world perspective of
venezuela iran north korea et cetera
there's a lot of talk about things that
they could potentially be doing with
crypto whether they're trying to mine it
buy it hold it whatever um but there's
other countries that obviously are
paying attention and they've
publicly talked about it what's kind of
your read
or experience with either the
corporations or the countries are there
things there that
um you've got like unique views on or
things that people just don't understand
yet
yeah so i'm very very very excited about
this
i think it's going to be absolutely
phenomenal
i think it's so early like we're
we're happy that elon and jack and
michael are in uh
that's like three companies right
there's 497 other companies just in that
group of of people
that are absolutely not coming close to
it um
at all and and it will be a while but i
think this is how it happens slowly
slowly than all at once
and the country stuff you bring up is
super interesting because
i think we need to saturate the sorry
the country stuff is super interesting i
think we need to saturate the companies
a little bit more it needs to be less of
a huge statement
for more companies to just have this as
part of their normal portfolio
composition as part of their normal
cash needs um and then countries will
follow
and they will follow first with
sovereign wealth funds which
are more of private equity venture
capital investments even if they're very
long
term minded and then at some point
central banks we've had very good
conversations with certain central bank
governors
um they're aware of it not yet
but in the same way that central banks
hold gold they will hold bitcoin one day
um and i think countries will come it
will be a very big deal
but companies need to
uh be a little bit more saturated first
and it's
super super early for that and by the
way if you're talking about like the big
big vision of bitcoin
everyone's talking about it replacing
gold if bitcoin becomes the new reserve
currency
like the crazy estimates that you know
we read about of
10 to 30 million dollars per coin you
need
sovereign holders you need corporate
holders and you need
that to be standardized so maybe that's
a 10-year thing
i think that bill gates said it best we
overestimate what we can do in one year
we underestimate what we can do in 10
but i do think this could happen much
much faster than that
and i think that uh michael sailor in
the corporate world was like a perfect
example it almost feels like there's uh
the first one to break the seal
yeah then you get the early adopters
right you still don't get mass
adoption so your point 497 companies
still haven't done it right
but one led to three and it's no longer
as big a deal yes it normalizes a little
bit there's it's more of a conversation
there's literally cfos and those other
497 companies are like
should we do this they have to come up
with a strategy somehow maybe we should
go to a competition
we can learn about it right like there's
a lot of stuff that happens countries
are going to be the same way
and maybe it's one does it and then one
other follows
right and then it's just two and it's
only two for a while but
i do feel like we're getting close to
this point where
uh a country that is doing it not to get
around
sanctions but is doing it from a pure
financial benefit standpoint
is going to embrace it and when that
happens i then think that
uh there's a kind of a fast follower two
three four five however many
uh the bigger thing that i've got
confidence in though it's not gonna be
the united states
it's not gonna be a major country right
it's much
easier for the smaller countries to go
ahead and do this of course
and to essentially say listen this is my
opportunity
right if this thing is going to be real
and this thing is going to have global
importance well
i can use speed to benefit
in a more outsized way than those who
have larger dollars larger economies
you know more kind of firepower from
military standpoint whatever
and so to me it just is like kind of the
mid-level and down somebody in that
bucket is going to be able to
uh kind of get it together and do it
we're
recording this in may of 2021 by the end
of this year i think we'll see it
i completely see that and um to be fair
my
10-year horizon is when it becomes
ubiquitous
i think it will stay fair i think it
will take 10 years for it to become
ubiquitous
uh but how long does it take the u.s you
think
the us doesn't need to be first that's
the thing that's the thing that you know
people don't realize er it's really hard
to turn an oil tanker
uh or i guess this is like a carnival
cruise ship you know i was gonna say
yeah oil tankers were much bigger 400
million people on it
um than it is to move a small sailboat
that will just turn on a dime
and the us does not need to move fast
the us needs to make sure that not
everything breaks
and that's that's a different
consideration entirely which is fine
which is completely fine uh i agree with
you i think someone
um will do it this year it will be a
small country
and there's an opportunity there's a
huge opportunity for a number of
countries to go in
what happened with bulgaria don't they
have 200 000 bitcoins
did they sell those they claimed that
they sold them they sold them
they claim who knows uh the u.s claims
that they don't have any either anymore
right because they compromise they
auctioned it off uh maybe
i don't know look it's um it's kind of
like folks on wall street for a while
you just bought some just in case we
didn't tell anybody
and then all of a sudden if it works
you're like oh i bought it back you know
two years ago i look at how smart i am
and if it didn't work then you just
don't tell anybody ever right nobody
knows and so like
why take the reputation risk or the uh
in this case geopolitical risk if you
don't have to yet
it's like my guess is that some of these
countries already holding it right it's
just who's the first to come out and say
it
yeah right because that's like another
thing is if you separate out do the
action from the announcement
like the action's probably already
happened in some of these countries and
it's gonna be a
um like a national security thing to not
hold it i think
in in a few years time and don't know
when but at some point it will be
prudent to hold
this um and you're starting to see some
countries uh
trying to regulate mining more like more
mining hash power should come here or
um you can only use locally mined
bitcoins it's so that's crazy but that
says something about the national
security apparatus
thinking about this under the lens of
national security so from a
sovereign central bank perspective yeah
they'll hold it
strategically forget economically
because
i think countries are mostly driven by
uh surviving versus thriving and there
there's a
there's a subtle but important
difference and so if national security
necessitates holding crypto you're going
to get a lot more holders than
the economic opportunity agreed but this
whole idea of like
uh special bitcoin is all [ __ ] my of
course
like green bitcoin uh my friend kevin
o'leary i keep giving him a hard time he
keeps talking about blood coin right
meaning like
you know bitcoin that's not uh um mined
with uh renewable energy
uh now you're getting all sorts of uh i
think my buddy marty bent said uh virtue
signaling bitcoin
uh mark cuban only buys like uh freshly
mined bitcoin allegedly
something yeah uh locally mined bitcoin
right i mean there's all these little
things that we were trying to do trying
to create a whole foods for bitcoin
it's all nonsense this is organic right
there's 21 million bitcoin if i have a
bitcoin you have a bitcoin and
literally we trade them yeah and now i
still have a bitcoin you have a bitcoin
it doesn't matter
it's just like dollars right imagine if
somebody said you know what i'm only
going to take dollars that are freshly
appointed from the federal reserve
right or i'm only going to get dollars
that have uh been held by one person
yeah now technology's not there to do it
obviously so you couldn't do it here you
could actually track some of this stuff
but i just think that it's ridiculous
and it almost feels more like
intellectual stimulation than any sort
of actual real world
uh applicability what do you think i
feel like for certain people it's just
another excuse
like oh i'm not investing in this
because um
renewable energy and then you look at
their stock portfolio and it's a bunch
of coal-powered companies and you know
african mining uh based corporations do
you wanna know what i think somebody
should do
what i'm definitely gonna get in trouble
with planet for saying this but i'm
gonna say it anyways
so you know how just another day right
yeah you know how uh the media loves to
write these articles
all about um the bitcoin miners
and how they consume so much power and
like they're rotating the planet
i'm waiting for a bitcoiner to write an
article that says that the media
how many trees get cut down every year
so they can print their newspapers and
magazines and they're ruining the
environment
right and kind of like okay hold on here
like you fight fire with fire
you want to have these ridiculous stupid
articles like here come ours
i will take this back to our research
team i'm literally going to run the
numbers on this you might see something
soon right like
think about it for a second it's really
interesting we should shut down all of
the newspapers and magazines because
they cut down too many trees
yeah like you're killing the environment
you're destroying the planet if you
don't use a kindle right like
it's kind of crazy why do you guys still
have this so like
it's almost to this degree of like it's
an absurd argument
and there's no scientific or
mathematical
uh like application that is used
in this analysis like literally just
like look how much power they use let's
compare it to countries it's like
the electric grid is also really hard to
explain and to understand and so
look at how much it says nothing yeah
let's do the dollar
right or or how much electricity is used
by the media organizations to just keep
the lights on so they can write articles
yeah yeah right and you start to do all
this stuff and like what you realize is
like look by the way
i'm not here claiming that bitcoin
doesn't use energy
right but i do think that the context is
really really important
and on top of that the you know was it
75
renewable energy or what like all these
little details get left out of the story
and so i think that that's like the
world we're headed to is whether it's
hey i have green bitcoin or locally
mined bitcoin
uh or i was used on energy efficient
bitcoin or you know what whatever people
come up with it's all crazy i do think
though
that this year we'll probably start
seeing some esg bitcoin
and people will do you think it trades
at a different price maybe
like we're thinking about it really yeah
we get a we got a ton of requests from
um so this is where i would
differentiate between the two right i
think there are certain people who
are absolutely judged vehemently against
it
and are looking for an additional excuse
and then i think there are people who
are constrained
by their fund mandate or their own rules
or their country's rules
from investing like a lot of a lot of
listed um products um in in certain
countries are unable to buy bitcoin
one of one of the reasons why because it
looks just big regulations
just local regulations one of the
reasons why we've been successful is
that we've come in and we've securitized
it
for fund managers whose mandates would
otherwise preclude them from investing
in physics they can invest in a fund
they can't
exactly directly exactly and so off of
that i would be a proponent of
if if you need an esg um
entry point because of certain fund
requirements that you have in geneva
that's okay let me figure out some clean
energy mines
get you in that way because you're ready
to come in your rules just prohibit you
from doing that and i think we should
differentiate between the two
even though i agree with your bigger
argument that over the long run
um i think bitcoin will be a huge
huge part of solving
the climate crisis not i think it's not
in the other i think right now it's
probably
the number one or one of the top r d
drivers of renewable energy in the world
in addition to that um
carbon taxes which are actually the
solution but no one is politically able
to do it
um bitcoin will be able to put an
economic uh
component to the energy grid and to
clean energy and do global warming
in a way that nothing else will so i
think in the long run
i agree with you absolutely and it will
be
clearer uh the more time um
runs by but in the short term
if i can do something to bring more
people into the crypto ecosystem
let's do it and by the by the way in a
in a we have a product that does that
already
in in a different way so we have a swiss
product we have a product that
is an index of bitcoin and ethereum
that is in swiss francs with swiss
custody swiss trading
um swiss everything swiss branding two
swiss issuers
there's a certain set of people who will
only want to invest in swiss products i
don't know if you know this but with
gold etfs there are gold etfs that are
only swiss gold
it's viscosity gold and they charge a
premium for that
and people feel more comfortable doing
that we've launched that product
it has tens of millions of dollars does
it trade at a premium
it does not trade at a premium maybe
maybe these are good ideas from pomp
that we should incorporate i'm not
saying uh detroit no no it doesn't trade
at a premium trades at the same price
as everything else but certainly these
tens of millions of dollars that are in
this product it's just an index of
bitcoin and ethereum right there are
a lot of complementary products out
there um i'm glad we brought them in
somehow
and i would do the same thing with esg
i'd do the same thing with a few other
things
but i think it's different when you're
saying hey i need a swiss
uh security i need swiss um
you know license i need a swiss exchange
i need a swiss
issue or whatever those are all things
are true
right there you're not gonna convince me
that a bitcoin is different
depending on where it was but you're not
the one that's being convinced what you
will have is you have a fund manager
who's bullish
who believes bitcoin will replace gold
who believes all of that and he wants it
and then his compliance department needs
to take the box on an esg
requirement i would but what i'm saying
is
uh and i'm never going to talk to his
complaints about it no i'm not i'm not
having that conversation
what i'm saying though is it's a mirage
right because the bitcoin is the same
either way yes so what you're basically
doing
is uh if you think of it from a first
principle standpoint you're literally
making up a whole charade to simply be
able to buy it which but fine okay
if you acknowledge that what i'm saying
the difference is if you say hey i need
a swiss regulator
right or a swiss issuer you go it's
either it's true or false
are they swiss issuers i guess it
becomes i guess that's where i disagree
with it i think it becomes it's a mirage
over the medium and long term as
some of this stuff becomes clear and
plays out in the short term
it's a valid concern for someone that is
legally
and by regulation required to show
everything that they invest in and it's
environmental output and that's
difficult to do if you're just buying
bitcoin on an asian exchange
i completely agree that it's difficult
to do all this stuff what i'm saying
though is that's a
uh investor problem that's not a bitcoin
problem it's not a bitcoin product right
because if that was the case
no but if that was the case then they
shouldn't hold dollars i agree
i don't think it's a bitcoin problem at
all but um
we should help those kinds of investors
that want to come in
but can't do to some handcuffs here or
there change the rules
[Laughter]
you should do both both actively i think
that we could agree yeah
um what are you most excited about
moving forward
like next 12 months what's the thing
that you're like industry-wise not
necessarily for the company because then
you'll have to say
things uh no we don't want me to
say things um i can come on my podcast
and not talk
of course of course um
i think i have been really really really
surprised
by what has been going on with defy and
i think we talked about it actually the
last time i was here very briefly like
things are interesting there yeah that
has escalated
um to a point where uniswap now on
certain days does more volume than
coinbase
i think on an annualized basis it's like
a fourth it's very ridiculous yeah
they're trading volume um sushi swap
came out of nowhere pancake swap came
out of nowhere there's so much
innovation
what is that what the names what is up
with the names it's good
i love it ethereum has more of a you
know
rainbow kittens meme vibe about projects
and that's
what is what it is the community by the
by the way you have to do research on
sushi swap and explain that to people
listen if i'm a huge believer that
communities drive their culture
yeah right and if the community wants
something
not only are they going to create it but
like who is anybody outside of the
community to judge
right so like the naming conventions
also like
to me i'm like how do they think of
pancake swap right yeah but also i'm
like by the way
is that that's what they want awesome
yeah yeah right like
it's great i have yet to have somebody
come in here and have a conversation
about this stuff and not start laughing
as we talk about the names
which is almost part of the fun right
and if anything it has infected the
other uh part and so chef nomi is the
you know head of sushi swap
what's the cfo of tesla's title again
yeah right master of coin master of coin
techno king tesla exactly and so i think
it it goes it goes both ways but
what's going on in defy is really early
and really really exciting i'm i'm
confused a little bit still about nfts
um i think that it's really exciting to
see
bitcoin become so standardized
i i i think most people are starting to
come around
to the inevitable outcome of bitcoin i
was going to say is it a foregone
conclusion at this point
it's close it's close nobody wants to
say it
but like i kind of feel like well um
and i'm really excited about that what
are you excited about
same stuff as always like to me it's a
foregone conclusion it's been for a
while but uh i think like really not
like
uh you have congressmen and senators
with laser eyes
yeah yeah right and mayors you have
mayors we're sitting in miami right you
have
uh people who work at some of the most
conservative organizations in the united
states
that are all accepting this using it
buying it holding it like it's not going
away
yeah and if it doesn't go away the
properties of the asset
are going to continue to affect this
like apex predator
um mechanism in the market that's going
to continue to suck liquidity out of
other assets
it's like one of the things that i think
nobody's really talking about is
when bitcoin flips gold is not happening
to 10 trillion
no no not at all it's happening at like
8 trillion
right and why it's because bitcoin is
going to continue to grow
but also gold's market cap is going to
contract like gold is a dying asset
which sounds nuts to people but what we
are watching is we are watching a new
asset that is digital
slay an analog asset and
some of it is causation some of it's
just pure correlation
but literally as over the last six to
eight months bitcoin has gone up 600
percent
gold is down yeah but you know why it's
not inevitable yet
why bitcoin winning because i think it
will be inevitable when
you as the manager of a treasury
somewhere at a
corporation would have job risk
of if you do not invest in crypto
where you could be fired if you do not
have a crypto allocation where it's
that obvious and you but i think that
that's already like in the inevitability
like that's already going to happen it's
going to happen it hasn't happened yet
which is why i'm saying i don't
think i don't think today it
that's why i said we're close we're not
quite there because it's
fair yeah you want more uh i want you
more risk aversion than me i want you to
be
more yeah if you have a risk of getting
fired from your job
if you don't invest in crypto that's
when we've won
is there another asset where people have
that risk
i mean like if you don't hold public
equities i guess like you're considering
but if you're holding if you're if
you're managing some portfolio or some
treasury
and you're not yeah if you're not
holding normal equities equities
if you're not using some sort of hedging
mechanism in a basic way like
maybe people will question you and if
you don't if you have zero allocation to
crypto maybe
maybe then your sharp ratio is so wrong
that clearly you don't know what you're
doing you're not you're not
fulfilling your duty something exactly
yeah
all right where can we send people to
find you on the internet at handy on
twitter is the best way
did we talk about last time how you got
that handle just a
very very early twitter user you just
went in and typed it in or like
let's go for name very early twitter
users all right winning combination
uh and then 21 shares in a moon
21shares.comamun.com
both.coms yeah 21 shares nobody has
we're getting good names right yeah
21 shares nobody had 21 shares we had to
buy oh is that moon
no no we we paid a really uh
a pretty low price for a low price
pretty low price i think it was a couple
thousand bucks
wow all right that's fine you should
they should have taken a bitcoin exactly
maybe better
hi my friend thank you so much for doing
this thanks for having me always fun